five high school students in Michigan
are accused of throwing rocks off an
overpass and killing a man
Kenneth white was 32 years old he was a
father of four children he was riding
home last week when a rock hit him and
killed him the five suspects are 15 to
17 years old they are all charged with
second-degree murder Adriana Diaz is at
the Genesee County Jail in Flint
Michigan where the oldest suspect is
being held
Adriana good morning good morning the
teenager who prosecutors believed
actually dropped the rock a 17 year old
Kyle anger he's 1 being held here at the
county jail the other is at a juvenile
detention facility they were all
arraigned yesterday and are being tried
as adults the five teenage defendants
were expressionless as their lawyers
entered not guilty pleas for them my
client has no criminal record whatsoever
they're distraught families watched the
proceedings so did the grieving father
of Kenneth white the 32 year old victim
I buried my mother and my father and my
oldest brother in the last four years
this is the hardest thing I've ever did
in my life police say white a
construction worker was getting a ride
home in a Ford Econoline van around 8:30
p.m. last Wednesday that's when a six
pound rock about five inches wide and
eight inches long was allegedly dropped
from an overpass and crashed through the
windshield the father of four was struck
in the face and chest
he was declared dead on arrival at the
hospital not a prank a second-degree
murder officials say after the incident
the suspects went to McDonald's
investigators say they found at least 20
rocks on Interstate 75 one weighed more
than 20 pounds
Frank Manley and Fred Myers represent
two of the defendants marcsa kelskiy and
Trevor gray how's your client doing
scared he feels devastated for the
victim and the family I think there's
been a public rush to accept that these
kids are bad that they're almost
animalistic and they should be punished
as such Your Honor mr. Miller
understands the serious nature of the
suspects face up to life in prison
but Kenny white senior the victim's
father says that's not enough even if
they spend 30 years in prison they get
to wake up every single morning
phone calls from their parents they
still get visitors my son no get none of
that no more that was taken away from
them for something stupid investigators
believe the suspects also dropped attire
and car engine parts from another
overpass nearby damaging other vehicles
they were denied bail and are due back
in court November 2nd Nora
really disturbing story Adriana thank
you